hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be answering all of your
nitty gritty property questions
[Music]
here's the thing generally speaking on
youtube you might just get like big
picture stuff maybe house tours or
here's how i made 100 000 pounds but i'm
here to answer all the niggly questions
that you might have so if you've got any
questions at all you've always wondered
why don't you go ahead ask below in the
comments and then i'm going to do my
very best to answer your questions and
while you're doing that i'm going to be
answering some of the questions from
last week's q a sunday video also as
always the first thing that you need to
become financially free through property
is a good mindset and to smash the like
button so go ahead smash the like button
right now and let me start answering
some previous questions we had so kirsty
eaton hey kirsty how you doing she says
how did you find or do you suggest
others to find
good business advisors
or property tax advisors to correctly
set up your companies from the start
all right so firstly do i suggest doing
that i would say absolutely yes
building a business is the same as
building a house when you build a house
you want to get your foundations right
first you want to get a plan of exactly
how you're going to build what you're
going to build and i think this is
massively underrated in business if
you're starting a property business you
need to think about are you going to
what strategy are you gonna use are you
gonna set this up in a limited company
or are you gonna buy in your personal
name so you do need to get that set up
in terms of where do you find those
people i would probably find somebody
who's succeeding in property that you
know and if you don't know anybody
that's succeeding in property at all
then you probably need to get in some
different rooms and make some new
friends and ask them who did you use who
who was your business coach who was your
accountant who was your solicitor who
were your builders who were your
architects and start bringing a team
together tell them your plan
speak out your plan bring people on
board with your plan as well so you're
not alone and then once you've got a
plan in place then you can go to town go
to work roll your sleeves up and start
getting some deals that's my advice i
hope that helps
all right george shorts
when moving a kitchen to another room
would an architect an architect be
needed or could i just use a builder
so if you're moving a kitchen to another
room you're not going to need any
planning permission or anything like
that so you could just get a kitchen
fitter and just say hey i want to put
the kitchen over to this room or i want
to
um
there's a little bit of crossover
between you know laborers and then
builders and then architects and then
ultimately you know consultant planning
consultants experts um so it depends on
the size of the kitchen if it's like a
nice kitchen and you want to make it
done well and you want it done properly
it probably would be worth speaking to
an architect if it's just a cheap and
cheerful house and you're just moving it
along you may well be able to just get a
builder to do that you don't need
anything designed so it really depends
on the size and the spec of the house
if you do get a builder to do it make
sure they're a good builder and make
sure they have got some basic design
skills in place maybe ask them to show
you some other kitchens they've designed
before you give them the job
hope that helps if you're enjoying the
video don't forget hit the like button
if you haven't already and i'm desperate
for your questions i love giving
property advice and information and
guidance from my experiences so let me
know your questions emma lundy
i'm a new deal sorcerer and i've been
told by an investor that they want off
market deals and deals that haven't been
seen by anyone else
what's the best way to go about it as
i've got this to the stage where i was
revealing the details of the deal to
them and got told that they didn't want
it as it was on the market and they
didn't want to deal with agents they
want to go direct to the seller what is
the best way to find these sellers and
resolve this problem as i spent lots of
time doing my due diligence and research
for this deal
all right emma first thing i'm going to
say is there's a chance
a small chance that these deals that you
keep passing telling these investors
about and they go now i'm not interested
because it's on market or whatever
that they're just going and buying them
anyway and cutting you out of the deal
so i don't know how many times this has
happened but it's very possible that
you've been losing thousands and
thousands of pounds as a result of this
so the first thing i'll say is
if you're gonna ever
ever
pass a deal onto somebody before you
give them the information you need to
make sure that they sign a
non-disclosure agreement or pay you a
fee
even if there's a calling off period if
your investor's saying that he's looking
for off-market deals only then i would
probably um
get a bespoke finder's fee from him
say look you tell me exactly what you
want
and then i will take a 1 000
refundable fee from you
if i manage to find what you're looking
for within the next two months
then you can pay me the difference
maybe an extra two grand and then you
got the deal if i can't find it i'll
give you one thousand pounds back
do not spend hundreds of hours
looking for a deal for somebody and that
person could just be a complete time
waster so find out what they're looking
for take a bespoke sourcing fee of them
then go to town and find what they want
i don't know if this is helpful but this
is i'm speaking from experience i've
sold hundreds of deals and i've dealt
with thousands of
investors george butcher is buying a buy
to let's still a good idea
i would say that buying a standard
vanilla buy to let firstly depends on
the buy to let if the return on
investment is less than 10
then it's not a good idea
if it's more than 10 then it's a decent
idea i mean it's considerably better
investing in buy to let property than
than putting money in a bank because if
you put it in the bank you're going to
get nothing in fact the interest that
you will get from the bank which is
margin tiny is not even going to be
enough to keep up with inflation so buy
till it has its place however when you
understand how to invest in property the
smart way
namely
by adding value and then refinancing by
renting out a property room by room or
on serviced accommodation you will
probably never want to go back to
vanilla buy to let again
so i don't think it's a bad idea
but i don't think it's the best way to
make money james ward parish
one thing i don't understand yet is if
you're selling deals how do you pitch an
investor a deal and get paid for it
without them thinking cool i'll do that
while saying nah that one isn't the one
for me
i feel like it'd be so easy to lose
deals to people and never get paid for
them
so james first thing is every business
deal
okay there has to be a fair exchange
going on
fair exchange what does that mean that
means that you need to be getting paid
for your value now if the if the
investor just thinks why would i pay you
i can find it myself then that kind of
investor probably won't pay you because
they'll just go and do it themselves
but there's a lot of investors out there
that haven't got the time they haven't
got the inclination they haven't got the
energy they haven't got to go out and
view 20 houses on a tuesday afternoon in
the rain
negotiating that they don't want to do
that they want to pay they want to pay
you to do that and if you can find a
house that's worth 200 grand and
negotiate it down to 150 that's a 50 000
pound discount
they'll pay you five grand so it's about
finding people that number one
want the service of a deal source anyone
that says i'd never pay anyone to find
me a deal then great
good luck in your your search but i
can't help you
you'd be like if someone said to me you
know oh i'd never paid you to go on one
of your courses
great
don't you just watch the youtube videos
then you don't have to be mentored you'd
have to this is the service this is how
much it costs if people don't want to do
that then that's that's that's their
prerogative it's the same with any
business i would never pay more than ten
thousand pound for a range rover
range rover aren't going to freak out
and try and persuade you
to buy a range rover they'll go no
problem there's a ford garage down the
road cheerio so there's no issues
in terms of
how do you make sure that they actually
pay you and and don't just say no that
isn't for me
listen to what your customers want
business 101 ask them what is it that
you're looking for in a deal tell me
help me understand great
if i can find something like that
would you be interested in having a look
i'm a deal sourcer my fees are generally
three to five thousand pounds for a deal
would you be interested in having a look
if they say yeah i would then great find
what they're looking for pick up the
phone tell them what you've got and if
they're interested and they want to go
ahead
close them
take their money pass them the deal
brilliant do that once a month
and you don't need a job anymore
and all the best juiciest deals that you
find on your search
you're going to keep for yourself
that's how deal sourcing works
last question if you've got a question
comment below i'll take the last
question right now this is from
masaab ali he says
mr samuel
how can you tell if the area you're
buying is in a good area
so what do you mean by a good area
presumably you mean a good area to
invest in property so
firstly you don't want to buy properties
generally speaking in the best areas
like look at london what are the areas
in london that have gone crazy crazy
high in capital appreciation over the
last 10 20 years often it's been not the
best areas
places like brixton and catford and some
of these areas that have been and are
being regenerated
are actually the best if you look at
westminster and some of the really
expensive parts of london i mean not
only are they very hard to buy because
they're so expensive but they've
actually not really done much in the
last couple of years so
i'm not looking for necessarily the most
expensive beautiful luxurious area i'm
also not looking for the worst area i
don't want to buy in a street where
there's there's broken glass and
mattresses dumped out on the road and
boarded up windows and you're probably
going to end up getting stabbed when you
do your viewing i don't i'm not about
trying to buy a house in that area why
because that means that my tenants are
just going to be
probably
not great tenants so i'm looking for
like not a one not a ten more maybe like
a three or a four
how do you find out if what the area is
like and if the area is good or bad if
you're going to be investing in an area
you have to get to know the area well
i'd be getting a map i'd be picking up
the phone speaking to letting agents
asking them the good areas the bad areas
the streets the market understanding in
the same way that when you're selling
deals you have to understand your
investors because they're your customers
when you're investing in property
yourself you have to understand your
tenants because they're your customers
what do they want who are they where do
they want to live what are they what
spec so you've really got to understand
your area by speaking to other investors
by speaking to agents by speaking to
letting or property managers
learn the areas find the supply find the
demand and then invest and know your
numbers so i could spend three hours
answering that question but i hope
that's enough to get the juices flowing
and to give you some really useful
information
my name's samuel if i can help you in
any way in your property journey drop a
comment below add me on instagram as
well if you want to check my instagram
page out it is samuel leeds official and
feel free to dm me i try and respond to
every single dm that i got on instagram
if you want to join me and you want to
spend a day training with me learning
about property i actually have got some
free tickets on the house available
right now they're very limited so you
have to be quick but if you get down to
the link in the description if they're
still available get booked on and i'd
love to meet you in person and train you
up in property for free
so guys thanks so much for watching i'll
see you soon god bless peace out
[Music]
you